soir un débat a commencé cet après midi
à l'assemblée nationale et les premières
interventions ont prouvé que les quatre
séances prévus ne suffiront peut être
pas il s'agit du projet de loi relatif à
la protection sociale commune à tous les
français étant donné la diversité
actuelle des régimes une compensation
serait institué entre eux c'est en fait
toute la réforme de la sécurité sociale
dont il s'agit un projet qui rencontrent
une certaine opposition de la part des
centrales syndicales des partis de
gauche et de diverses organisations
familiales et sociales
si elle était votée cette réforme
entrerait en application le 1er janvier
françois goneau nous en rappelle le
contenu quelque peu modifié depuis son
adoption par le conseil des ministres
lors de sa tenue à lyon
regardez bien ces allumettes et vous
allez comprendre ce qu'est exactement le
système de compensation entre les
différents régimes de sécurité sociale
un système il est vrai un peu complexe
car il n'existe pas une seule et unique
sécurité sociale il existe plusieurs
régimes
or ces différents régimes sont
déséquilibrés l'un par rapport à l'autre
regardez bien ici vous avez le régime
général des salariés
67 % de la population française puis à
côté on trouve le régime agricole 18%
3ème régime celui des commerçants
artisans et professions libérales 8%
enfin des régimes spéciaux des mineurs
et des cheminots 5% alors entre ces
différents régimes
c'est un peu comme entre le pot de terre
et le pot de fer le nombre des salariés
s'accroît d'année en année en forçant le
régime général tandis que l'effectif des
commerçants des mineurs ou des
agriculteurs est en constante diminution
en fait d'un régime à l'autre à cause
justement de ces déséquilibres
démographiques les cas entre les
prestations où l'écart entre les
retraites varient parfois du simple au
double à partir du 1er janvier 1975
le gouvernement entend donc compenser
corriger les inégalités financières
entre les régimes selon le principe
en somme des vases communicants exemple
le régime général le plus puissant
compensera les autres régimes pour
4 milliards de francs en 1975 mais bien
sûr le régime général ne fera pas cadeau
de ses 4 milliards de francs aux autres
régimes
cette charge nouvelle lui sera
intégralement remboursée par l'état
chaque année en effet l'état affectera
au régime général
le montant des taxes sur la
commercialisation des alcools et si
cette garantie de ressources se révéler
insuffisante lors des prochaines années
le budget de l'état fournirait alors la
différence de précision importante pour
terminer de précisions apportées hier
par michel durafour le ministre du
travail
d'une part cette réforme n'aura pas pour
effet de diminuer les prestations de
chaque régime ni de bloquer l'évolution
des prestations du régime général
enfin les salariés du régime général ne
supporteront aucune cotisation
supplémentaire que tout à l'heure à
21h30 que les députés vont entrer dans
le vif du sujet cet après midi michel
durafour le ministre du travail a
présenté ce projet de loi à l'assemblée
nationale un projet de loi amendé et la
commission des affaires culturelles et
sociales l'a réexaminée et l'a repoussé
pour la seconde fois
en fait ce projet gouvernemental se
heurte à une forte opposition bien sûr
ce n'est pas la généralisation de la
sécurité sociale à tous les français qui
fait se lever les boucliers le véritable
différence situe ailleurs il porte sur
le système de financement
c'est un coup au régime général de la
sécurité sociale affirme les opposants
qui est à travers ce projet distille les
salariés paieront pour les autres pour
le gouvernement les buts de cette
réforme de la sécurité sociale sont
claires généraliser la sécurité sociale
à l'ensemble des français
instituer une protection commune pour
tous les français harmoniser les
prestations et les cotisations de tous
les régimes
c'est de tout cela dont les députés vont
débattre tout à l'heure et puis pour
terminer je dois vous indiquer que les
députés ont repoussé une proposition des
socialistes qui estimait que le projet
de loi était irrecevable
résultat du vote
290 voix pour la discussion 186 contre
issy l'assemblée nationale à vous
cognacq jay